i have something to confess what
this morning at home i took uh i took a
half a dab
did you really
yeah i did sorry i didn't tell you
either and then
it ended up being fine it actually made
me way more calm than him and mr
knucklehead what do i look like now
you look fine it was a nightmare
nightmare
i only had it in my mouth for like five
minutes go ahead make your jokes
damn now i got the giggles are you high
like i don't know
i honestly i mean it's just i don't
think so you like taking acid to like
calm you down like before a nerve
nervous situation uh well sort of it
acts as kind of like adderall would hey
i'm on and i'm focused and i'm able to
so
in another world let's say you're a
you're a brain doctor you think you
would you would drop drop out before uh
before operating on someone's head i'm
gonna have to say no okay i wouldn't
because that would make me feel bad if i
[ __ ] up and then i would never know
wow if i hadn't taken the acid yeah but
what if this person be alive and you're
like i should have taken the ass that's
true well it's the eternal question if i
hadn't taken acid and gone on wheel of
fortune would i have won maybe are you
okay you're not making any sense
words i was worried about so to answer
your
[Laughter]
to questions your question i feel a bit
like the guy in space there just kind of
kicking around probably peeing his pants
the acid makes the beam up a little bit
more comfortable yeah exactly no i
understand that i hope i didn't upset
you or let you down by taking a drug
just feel like you should have told me
upset you or let you down by taking a
drug
you